do you ever
um
think about you know because there's
some people out there yeah you know when
you say oh you know I'm tired I'm this
and this and then they'll be like well I
was born and raised in Thailand you're
not a real Thai because you didn't you
didn't grow up like I did well this is
uh actually this is uh well this is
gonna get into like a pretty deep
conversation because I've seen this
comment not towards you but towards
other people that have been thrown
around a few times without like well I I
grew up there and you didn't so you
aren't part of I get that a lot with
Japan I imagine yeah yeah so it's like
how do you I mean well okay no one's
ever said that to me you know no one
said no one's ever said you're not Thai
and I think I would probably get
offended at some point because it's just
incorrect yeah yeah yeah exactly uh
hello if you look at my bloodline I'm
literally 100 Thai yeah but it's it's a
weird case because because I didn't grow
up in Thailand no one would there will
ever say that I'm not Thai but it's kind
of like the same thing in Japan where
there's this soft boundary where you'll
be treated a little bit differently
people will talk to you bit differently
and people will view you a bit
differently but on the opposite and the
side of things I I've always been always
viewed as an outsider in England as well
you know right I've never felt like I've
always felt like okay my parents
emigrated to England I am I'm I'm a
child of an immigrant basically I'm a
first uh first generation but does that
make me not British no but does that
mean that I had a different kind of
upbringing where I acknowledged that I
had a different Heritage yeah and it's
weird because I've met kind of like a
lot of Asian Americans and they have
like a totally different view than I do
right because like I was I was having a
conversation with some Asian Americans
and I was asking them do you find it
offensive if people ask oh where are you
from you know because I don't find that
offensive because when when I when
someone asked me in England for example
oh where are you from I assume the
context of that is where is your
heritage from where your person you know
but I think in America because some
that's like a very much more sensitive
topic and sensitive question because
I've heard I've talked to plenty of
Asian Americans that would get very
offended if someone asked them where
they're from but like if you're if
you're okay I mean I shouldn't say
something
if someone's Asian right yeah and you're
like oh what's like where in Asia are
you is like your your lineage your
bloodline I don't know whatever you want
to call it like where I that's something
like an interesting conversation to have
yeah and I I think the Nuance to that
question is that because a uh because
America is basically a country of
immigrants right you know um it's it's
kind of a like a slightly different
starting point being being uh and uh
Asian British yes yeah I guess I guess
to be honest I think like it's it's all
about the Nuance because it's like I
yeah because I mean you ask it yeah yeah
exactly it's like no because I remember
there was one time in America where like
this American girl asked me like oh
where are you from yeah and I said uh
you know and I said I'm from Australia
yeah and then she said no but where are
you from yeah and I'm like okay okay so
okay no no okay yeah yeah I'm like are
you asking about my Heritage yeah uh if
so then then you could have just said
what's your background yeah you know so
I think it's all about the context right
right and it's like bloodline sounds
really fun what is your bloodline that
sounds bad
that makes it sound like it's a [ __ ]
narrative got a [ __ ] Sharingan or
some [ __ ] you know I'm from the YouTube
all these DNA entry things are marketing
it way off yeah it's like you you should
find out your bloodline yeah what's your
bloodline I have like some epic
narration you know do a DNA test in this
Vibe we need to start normalizing that
when you want to know where someone is
from just go what's your bloodline
immediately you know what you're talking
about yeah yeah no but like I mean I had
the exact same thing in Australia as
well yeah like you know because it's
like I'm not first generation because
only only half of me is but like you
know I still grew up with a lot of like
Japanese Traditions at home yeah so and
you know I don't look like your typical
Australian whatever a typical Australian
looks like so and I don't look like your
typical Japanese either so it's like I
in both countries I had this like
identity crisis of like what the [ __ ] am
I yeah because no one else around me
knows what I am until I specifically say
what I am yeah and then that made me
confused being like Oh am I Australian
or am I Japanese because that I mean now
I know I'm just like I'm just both like
yeah that's that's just what I say to
people same here but like now you know
but then that's why like I'm starting to
get a little bit like jaded when people
ask the where are you from question in
like a really [ __ ] nuanced way
because it's just like just I know what
you're trying to ask me just don't beat
around the [ __ ] would you you're not
gonna offend me by asking what my back
background because I I think I think a
big difference is uh to to these Asian
Americans I've talked to they are very
much okay I'm a proud American America
is my home America is my nationality you
know and and then they separate that
from okay I'm American and this is my
Heritage whereas I think of it as I'm
Thai and British you know it's it's
weird the trade-off I have for this is
that I don't really have a home country
you know because I've never felt I've
never felt so strongly in one camp or
the other I've actually just feel like
I'm in both but by being in both I've
never been I've never felt I've never
felt 100 accepted in either but I've
never felt a hundred percent home in
like either either yeah do you feel like
it's impossible for you to ever feel
like 100 British in a way yeah I mean I
I guess so but I I guess that's why I've
lived in so many different countries
because I don't really have an
attachment to one home country you know
that's that's why that's that's that's
the perception I've been given where I
find it so easy to move to a new country
or new place because I'm like well I
don't really have any uh I I mean I I
feel like my Heritage is here but I
don't really have any ties personally
towards my feelings about this is my
home country or X is my home country
because to me anywhere can be my home
country you know am I wrong and say in
America isn't it like a big thing as
well for like uh a first uh first
generation immigrant parents to also
give their kids like very American
sounding names that's what I was about
to say I think it's like almost from my
understanding it's I don't know if how
common it is but from the people around
me that I know like uh kids with a you
know first generation immigrant parents
I think a lot of the parents almost
choose not to I guess feed their
children the their culture in America
because it's like they almost like kind
of oppress
their own culture towards their kids so
that they can like fit quote unquote fit
more with America because like I've
heard like a lot of my friends in
America who are you know first
generation Asian or whatever like
immigrant parents a lot of them can't
speak their parents all the time it's
quite normal it's quite normal I feel
it's quite normal in America though and
only in America for some reason it's no
I think it's pretty normal in the UK as
well in the UK yeah I know a lot of
people in the UK who
um who their parents made the decision
to not teach like they didn't it wasn't
even like laziness they like their
parents made the decision to not teach
their
um child their mother tongue right
because they wanted to be able to I
guess assimilate and see that's
fascinating because in Australia it's
the polar opposite right it's like
almost every Australian I know that has
immigrant parents yeah they can speak
their mother tongue to some level of
capacity and they're proud of it yeah
exactly well I think I think I don't
know why one thing that really surprised
me about Sydney in Australia is that
there are all it's so cultural yeah I
didn't realize it was this Multicultural
like I think when we were at Sydney uh
smash I was like they there are so many
Asian Australians and just you know a
lot of Southeast Asians and I'm like
damn I've never seen these this many
Southeast Asians in another country
since I was lost in Southeast Asia I was
like what the hell what the hell man
yeah yeah and and it's like and again
it's like fascinating that because
Australia is such a multi-cultural
country yeah and and yet for some and
and you know America is as well I would
say just as much if not more than
Australia yeah and yet there was just
this like almost polar opposite
dichotomy of teaching or embracing your
parents cultures yeah yeah that aren't
American or aren't Australian would you
teach your kids your second language or
your first language
because it's like if I'm not in that
country it makes no sense to teach them
that language
um it's just because of how how small
and very Niche the language it's not
like yeah hey I can I can take if it's
time right oh hey I can take you to
Thailand you can use it it's like a
ticket of Wales maybe we'll find someone
at one time you might be able to you
know what I mean yeah if you don't live
in that country yeah and also if I
didn't it's it's very it's my language
is it there's a lot of difficulties that
come with a dying language yeah uh and
preserving it right and when you're
outside of the country where they're
trying to preserve it it becomes like 20
times more difficult to preserve the
language it is it is and it takes
especially when if you want to teach
your kid a language that they don't use
in this country yeah it takes effort
because it's it's part you know it's
like do you want to teach your kid
English in Japan easy do you want to
teach your kid Japanese in Australia
very doable do you want to teach your
kid any Asian language in London very
renewable it's like it depends on like
where you are and like if I was in Japan
the odds of me being able to be like hey
go go talk to all these other Welsh kids
it's like oh wait there are none okay I
don't because like the reason the reason
I asked this is because I've like I've
I've made the decision that I'm going to
teach my kid Thai as much as possible
even if they yeah even if they never use
it because the thing is I can I the only
person who ever spoke Thai to me growing
up was my mum and because of this I I'm
not like 100 100 fluent in time but if I
really want to go out of my weight and
study it like Joey of Japanese I could I
could get fluent you know because the
base level is there yeah I just feel
like I want my kid to have the same
upbringing as me where I feel like the
reason I have such a big attachment to
Thailand even though I didn't actually
grow up there it's because I can speak
Thai and I think just knowing the
language is such is such a big barrier
of Entry of just appreciating a culture
oh God just appreciating your heritage
right and I think if you don't know the
language you have to like you have to
work way harder to appreciate going to
this country and being like oh this is
uh this is where my parents are so
that's a really interesting point you
raised that because
again it this happens again with dying
languages yeah what about like whales or
other countries in Europe where there
are languages that are you know
obviously English or another language is
taken over but there was a language
before yeah which was the the ones
connected to everything cultural and
historical yeah are you then if you're
not re if like let's say because there
are a lot of people in like Wales and
Scotland and Ireland for example who are
raised generations and generations of
Irish Scottish or Welsh were raised in
their country yeah and none of them ever
spoke that the the language of the
original language yeah how would how
would you argue that that would affect
then your understanding of of the
country's culture in a sense
well I think that if you have if you
have this base level understanding of a
language even if it's dying out do you
how much of Welsh culture do you think
you understand more because you
understand Welsh right I mean playing
things like Elden ring and [ __ ] like
that seeing just a little pieces of
Welsh Welsh like native Welsh culture
everywhere I mean that's that's a cool
feeling right yeah yeah this I would say
it's you know you you can't ever be like
someone who's generations of families
raising country doesn't speak language
they're not they're not they don't
really understand that's that's not what
I'm saying yeah I know that yeah I know
at the end of the day I think like it's
just like if you're interested in it
regardless of how useful it is then you
know and you have an appreciation
towards it I don't think there's any
demerit in trying to learn it especially
at a young age when your brain is just a
sponge yeah exactly you know ingest
anything it's like you know like you
know you might not necessarily get say
in the case with Welsh for instance you
might not necessarily get a full on
understanding of the culture surrounding
it and anything but but at the end of
the day you can still say it's a cool
party trick at least you know at the end
of the day you can still say like I can
speak
[ __ ] Welsh yeah
but like when it comes to a dying
language right yeah I still think it's a
cool like if you I would be impressed at
anyone who knows how to [ __ ] speak a
dying language yeah right because it's
just cool and it's like and I feel
regardless of how useful that language
ends up becoming you just naturally grow
more of an appreciation towards language
towards culture towards Linguistics of
any country yeah I also another fun
Point well not a fun fun point or a fun
question let's say there's a an American
historian who wants to learn about Welsh
culture or say Thai culture yeah oh if
you've never lived or grown up in a
country can you get a as good if not a
better understanding of a country's
culture through studying and reading and
whatnot because I'm sure there are a
bunch of people who are not from uh
Thailand or not from Wales I'm from
Australia who've studied it way more
than we ever even have considered it
yeah who probably have a deeper
historical cultural understanding of
your country than you do yeah they might
have a they might have a deeper
historical understanding but they may
not necessarily have a deeper modern
understanding of it yeah I was Modern
wise but then you could argue that some
countries lose a lot of their cultural
uh like values in the modern world so
it's weird because I I thought about
this and I was thinking well I have this
very specific understanding of my
culture but it only goes so far and I'm
wondering how biased is that like based
on the area I grew up or the people I
interacted with yeah yeah because I'm
thinking oh this culture's like this for
sure but then someone else from the
other side of country might have had a
completely different experience of the
culture yeah and I always wonder about
that kind of stuff and I'm like oh man
this is like a such a so even R so then
it makes me just think what is the
[ __ ] point of being arguing about who
knows more about a culture or what
experience is right about a culture it's
like it's like I feel like almost yeah I
mean uh there is no right experience no
I I know but it's like it's you you I
found that with sometimes people would
get an argument about what is the
correct thing of ex-culture yeah and I
always found it interesting where it's
like yeah you have to recognize that
culture is also biased oh absolutely it
is culture is is even a historical
accounts of culture are somewhat biased
yeah yeah so it's like it's just such a
worm's nest of and then this all comes
back to the whole point the initial
thing I brought up of
people being like you don't know the
culture and it's like well it's like no
you've had your experience with the
culture yeah this is such a whole
rabbit's nest and and it all came from
this one comment that pissed me off
I saw this one comment and it pissed me
off because I was like [ __ ] you
um that was uh someone argued he was
like well I don't think God is Welsh
because he he left the moment he could
and his dad is English so [ __ ] him he's
not Welsh it's like well [ __ ] you I grew
up in the culture country for 19 years I
speak the language my mom is Welsh but I
don't even I don't even think I need
Welsh parents to be Welsh if I'm born in
a country and I'm raised there and I
speak the goddamn language I think
you're the [ __ ] of that country like
yeah yeah what are you talking about and
it's like did this dude just wake up
today and just feel like he wanted to
feel better than me I am the alpha Welsh
[ __ ] you you are merely the beta well
I'm like do you have do you have to stay
in a country to be like the moment you
leave America if you've lived there for
20 years you're not American anymore are
you [ __ ]
imagine wanting to then broaden your
horizons and experience another world
yeah yeah God forbid you want to
experience another culture I mean I mean
not all culture will stay the same our
experiences are going to change I mean I
don't know maybe you know you go back to
England and the Tesco meal deal is no
longer the price it was you're just like
okay I was talking [ __ ] on trash tastes
okay
it's not cheaper some more okay but I
mean yeah yeah
but like I I think especially in terms
of like understanding culture it's when
you have you found that when you go back
to your home country or place you
haven't visited for a long time your
personality also like subtly shifts to
what it was like before you moved out oh
it doesn't even subtly [ __ ] it like
full-on [ __ ] it's like people were
telling me my sister was telling me
while I was in Australia yeah the past
you know two and a half weeks that every
other day that she saw me she was like
your accent's getting thicker yeah yeah
and I was like is it because to me it
just sounds like the same I noticed my
accent getting like my British accent
like getting way way thicker just going
back yeah the frequency of in it was
definitely increasing
way more American I feel like I feel
like I got more American oh no yeah yeah
you definitely yeah in America yeah oh
yeah yeah no I mean you're 100 you're
influenced by you know the people around
you're surrounding with regardless of
which country you're in it's like that
um there was a study I think they did in
the uh one of the uh stations where they
are [ __ ] Antarctica what are those
remote [ __ ] places where there's snow
Antarctica one of the one of them what
are the [ __ ] places I don't know
they're so God damn England they did a
study because obviously a lot of the
times they're they're scientists from
different countries all shoved into one
place
this is very anecdotal don't take this
as in like uh all different countries I
think after uh weeks of them all staying
together like one of the accents became
like the more dominant and a lot of the
other actions were starting to kind of
shift towards I think it was German in
this study it was slowly started
becoming towards like a more German
accent weirdly you'd think maybe it'd be
American or something yeah and yeah it
was just kind of interestingly the
German guy spoke the most yeah maybe
let's just go like you are a hundred
percent a hundred percent influenced by
accents around you oh absolutely well
your action will change yeah yeah
depending on where you're staying and
it's not like a how dare you you've
forgotten your home accent Connor you'll
[ __ ] it's like no it's just
everyone works that way we want a copy
because that's we're animals and we're
social animals and we're designed Yeah
by [ __ ] Darwin I guess he decided
that all uh that we're gonna fit it
thank God Darwin Darwin invented the
Darwin patchness we were Alphas we would
remain this well you know you know why
we're we're [ __ ] we're we're
herbivores and betas is because we we
need other people's validation yeah so
that's why do I sound okay our whole
brain is designed that we need to fit in
we've got to fit in yeah that's why
sigmas exist like me who don't want to
fit in no I mean take my course right
now 100. this is what we call a
herbivore in denial
no I I I I I I I'm cripplingly and need
everyone's attention
do you know one of the stupidest [ __ ]
like uh one of the stupidest trends that
you know this whole Alpha movement of
like how to tell you I didn't go to
Alpha con is that a real thing
but but one thing I've actually yeah
yeah it is as bad as you think it is
yeah the post is just like a bunch of
white dudes I can't remember who told me
about alphagon I don't think it was you
I told you did you tell me about it okay
you should look at the poster for it
yeah I'll look at the poster for it hold
on yeah it's uh it's when you look at
photos and you see a girl and the guy
and you and there are like people that
are breaking down the angle that I like
these things the guys leaning in it's
like if you lean in you're the beta yeah
oh yeah oh [ __ ] way this is real yeah
that's real what the [ __ ] alphacon 2022
be great or be nothing
what a [ __ ] time tagline yeah that's
just like men in denial
this is just Macho insecurity the
convention it is it was like a scam oh
my God
yeah I love that angle thing yeah it's
like the beta leans in the woman the
woman better lean into the man or the
emancipator I've literally like
sometimes like a random picture will
show up in my timeline of just a guy and
you see like the the angles like it's
the red line of the guy being like okay
he's he's standing up with this he
should be standing up in an upright
position but he's at a he's at a 80
degree angle the woman is not bending
he's bending is the woman he's a beta
and I'm like maybe why would they not
just change this to misogynist and I'm
just like maybe the guy's just tall I
don't know maybe he's tired I don't know
I get it Alphas don't get tired they
just don't
oh my God I can't believe that's real